Justin Bieber is ready to rock the  Grammy stage Monday and et has all the  exclusive details on the singers mashup  medley oh baby you should go and love  yourself a source inside the sari  singers rehearsals ldt fever plans to  kick off his show with an acoustic  version of his hit song love yourself  then the Biebs will turn things up a  notch and collaborate with song  producers DJ Skrillex and Diplo to  perform where are you now the upbeat  song received a Grammy not for Best  Dance Recording the pop singer has yet  to win a Grammy but he revealed to ET  last December that taking home the award  is on his bucket list yeah hopefully  they just like well Bieber finally win  his first golden megaphone for his  latest album purpose tweet us using the  hashtag ET now